I thought I'd get here early free booze
I don't know if you could hear she said
how young and good-looking I looked that
close you probably couldn't hear that
and thank you you're talking about does
it get old basically or do you get
nervous or do you get I mean you're
always first of all the nice thing is
it's always nice when people are kind to
you you know and when people like the
products that you're making that's a fun
time because that doesn't happen all
that often as you know it's also fun
because I get to spend time with people
that I think a lot of a lot of people at
home think we all just hang out together
you know I think they think we have like
we're always at the Hilton drinking
champagne and the truth is I hadn't seen
Brad in about a year you know when I saw
him at the at the Globes or I think
maybe in Palm Springs just before that
so it's fun to catch up and it's fun to
see people that I like and that I
haven't seen in the long time and get to
meet people I've gotten to spend some
time with Gary Oldman who I really have
enjoyed spending time with so the all of
the other part of it the sort of
competition part of it that seems to be
a favorite topic of people they love to
pit Brad and I against each other to
coin a phrase and that the truth is
we're buddies and I have nothing but I
just really enjoy being around him and
seeing and being around all my other
friends viola and I you know viola had
her honeymoon in my house in Italy so
it's good to be around people that I
enjoy so there isn't really a whole lot
of you know not the rest of it there's
no trepidation really for me it's fun
because you know this is my second
nomination as a writer well that's fun
because we're always pitching projects
and it's nice to be able to go in and
say I think we could actually do the
screenplay and they let us now so
there's some advantages to those kind of
things but the truth of the matter is
what these are for for me it's just it's
an honor and it's nice because it comes
from people that you work with a lot
from every category and that's I mean
it's really nice it's fun every
time Alexander wins anything and he's
nominated for a couple of things here
for 33 or so director and screenplay and
picture so I have a I have a great
affection for him not just because I got
the chance to work with him and he gave
me a part of a lifetime but also because
he's done five films and he hasn't done
a bad one you know honest to god he's
got a he should make more films cuz he's
only made five but he's he's got the
best track record in the business so I'm
I'm always pretty happy for him